the universe is expanding so you have to
be more and more careful about what
happens in each thing because you want
to make sure that you know you you're
setting up whatever they're going to do
in The Avengers um in secret Wars and
all that
stuff oh my
God I can't can you I got
[Music]
it the MCU has been moving towards
greater diversity and representation the
three El represent a huge population of
the planet plus you what impact do you
hope your film will have on audiences
given your unique position and
contribution I mean yeah it's really
exciting to have three very different
women at the center of the film and to
have you know supporting characters who
are so interesting and and dynamic and
different as well I really hope people
want to see more of them in in the MCU
because I think they're so special Miss
Marvel was actually someone who I loved
from the comics so being able to bring
her to the big screen was really huge
for me so I really hope that there's a
you know a long life for these guys on
uh in in the Cinematic Universe it's
such Dynamic and distinct characters
like Carol Denver Monica Rambo and Kamal
Khan how did you approach unifying their
stories while honoring their individual
Journeys in the Marvels it was really
for me achieving that was about making
sure that their individual stories
impacted each other so that them sort of
overcoming their own individual issues
was instrumental and them connecting and
vice versa so them connecting more and
getting closer and reconciling their
issues with each other was also helping
their individual Journeys for me the
thought was that if we could get that
right then we could honor them all and
also include a lot about them given that
the Marvels is part of the larger phase
five of the MCU did you Vector in the
larger stage for future narratives or
were you not keen on that ever expanding
Universe
I really tried to let Marvel lead me in
that way because they have this big plan
the universe is expanding so you have to
be more and more careful about what
happens in each thing because you want
to make sure sure that you know you
you're setting up whatever they're going
to do in The Avengers um in secret Wars
and all that stuff I really leaned on
them to to guide like okay what would be
possible in this movie what was going to
be okay and what could we keep or what
should we stay away from in order to
make sure the overall arching story
worked the film serves as a convergence
point for various strengths of the MCU
particularly following Captain Marvel
and the M Marvel miniseries did you
navigate the complexity complexities of
integrating these narratives into a
cohesive sequel for sure sure yeah I
mean I think because this was you know
Captain Marvel 2 but it's also the
Marvels I wanted to make sure that we
learned a lot about Carol that we didn't
learn before you know in the first film
she has no memory and then by the time
she gets it we kind of or starts to get
it back we kind of you know move into
the next phase and then it's 30 years
later and she's you know beating up
Thanos and crashing through ships and we
don't really get time to pause and learn
who she is so I wanted to make sure that
we got a look into her past um we got to
visit places she she been meet people
who knew her in that in those
intervening years while also thrusting
Cala and Monica into this into her life
so it ends up being about all three of
them but it's you know Carol's life that
sort of is the thrust of the story um as
well as the con family being you know a
really important part of like the heart
of the film that was that was sort of
the the task I think for me in this
movie I'm so glad to know that you know
you actually weaved a Carol story into
this as well um so superhero films often
touch on larger themes alongside the
action lots are there any particular
themes or messages you aim to weave into
the fabric of the Marvels yeah I think
for me and this goes again into like
wanting to know who Carol was when she
wasn't like saving the world and and
knowing what it really felt like for her
to be to feel as though she had the
weight of the world on her should or the
universe really on her shoulders was the
importance of family and and how family
is what helps you have the strength to
Take On The World and that's why you
know her and Monica's relationship is so
important in the movie and why the con
family is so important the film
thematically that was something I was
really passionate
[Music]
about